welcome back to hell I'm Mephisto a blue
Ron cult meeting welcome back to New
rockstars I'm Eric Voss and this is
Mephisto watch deadline is now reporting
that our dark lord savior May indeed
appear in the MCU ironheart series
coming to Disney plus next year played
by Sasha Baron Cohen I thought we saw
the devil in Borat too now I was
hesitant discussing this before since it
was just a rumor only buzzed about from
not always reliable Anonymous scoopers
online but now very legitimate news
source deadline has reported quote a
source close to the production confirmed
to deadline that there has been talk on
the set about Cohen being part of
ironheart likely playing Mephisto Reps
for Marvel and Cohen have refused to
comment on any Cohen involvement in
ironheart or the larger MCU now if your
deadline you do not run with that unless
there is something there and I think
signs are pointing to mephisto's debut I
mean sure I have always been an
Adventist scene Mephisto science
importance ever since 2020. and yes I
like many of you was pretty surprised
that a show like ironheart would be the
one to introduce Mephisto kind of feels
like saying the next Fast and Furious
movie would introduce Santa Claus guess
the way that franchise is heightening is
possible but the more you look into
ironheart and everything Marvel Studios
has been teasing about it the Visto
actually starts to make a lot more sense
in the show so ironheart will be a sixth
episode series coming to Disney Plus in
2023 starring Dominique Thorne as Riri
Williams and MIT Engineering student
from Chicago who builds armor in the
style of Iron Man we will first meet her
in Black Panther wakanda forever where
trailer could have just shown her in at
least two versions of her armor a Mark 1
suit during a car chase and then later
in wakanda a Mark II suit she works
alongside shuri in the wakandan lab
hammers out a heart-shape and vibranium
she appears alongside queen ramonda
during an attack from Namor and blasts
off from wakanda and Mark II armor with
Tony Stark's Mark 50 style rocket
boosters and an internal heads up
display other promos have given us
different looks at her armor the villain
of this ironheart series will be Anthony
Ramos as Parker Robbins aka the hood a
criminal known for wielding guns that
fire bullets with mystical properties in
the comics Robbins gets his mystical
powers from a demon that is later
revealed to be dormammu but reportedly
in this series dormammu whom we saw in
the 2016 Doctor Strange film it doesn't
really have a human Avatar he's mostly
just a big purple face in the dark
dimension it sounds like dermamu is
instead being swapped out with Mephisto
a demon who's known to take many human
forms
heart trailer d23 and memphisto did not
show up in it brief summary we see Jim
rash's MIT liaison from Captain America
Civil War reprimanding Riri for one of
her experiments blowing up he says Miss
Williams you are not the first genius at
MIT and Riri says I'm an engineer the
best way to know things is to take it
apart and put it back together then you
can see what it's made of what I'm doing
that's iconic Parker Robin says anyone
who's ever accomplished anything iconic
in life has had to do some questionable
things to get it done what will you do
Riri Riri says I'm gonna build something
like him referring to Iron Man but then
she adds but you know better really it
was the panel with Anthony Ramos and
executive producer Ryan coogler and
Kevin feige that hinted at what Parker
Roberts might have meant by questionable
because they pitched this show as a
conflict between technology and dark
magic dark magic that might have been
unlocked through a deal with the devil
on the stage Anthony Ramos was
particularly foot and mouth in a way
that no other presenter was that day
that I saw this guy was definitely
scared of saying the wrong thing Parker
it's a it's a it's a deep deep dive into
a dark place he goes into unfortunately
but but I think on the inside Parker
believes truly that he
is doing good and has a love for his
crew and he has a love for his people I
don't want to get there I'm over here
trying to dance around the plot like
this because I can't give y'all the
Beats thank you for coming here Anthony
it's amazing no more he's dancing too
close but what's great is if you know
the character from the comics he deals
in the dark arts he deals in Magic and
when I was sitting there listening to
Ramos and feige I thought what are they
dancing around we saw what this guy's
deal is in the footage but now based on
these reports of Sasha Baron Cohen as
Mephisto in retrospect it really does
seem like Mikey was warning Ramos about
dancing too close with the devil as if
right before they walked out on stage
feige said do not say Mephisto now we
here at new rockstars have a precarious
relationship with spoilers but I gotta
spoil something for you right up front
here I gotta talk about my balls for a
second and how the sheath underwear
makes everything more comfortable sheath
makes boxers that are designed to keep
your balls off your legs every pair has
two individual compartments to keep
everything down there separate and cool
and comfortable you know one pouch for
your kangaroo Joey and another pouch for
Joey's knows sheath has a modern
ergonomic design intended to prevent
skin on skin contact for long durations
which you know can build up heat and
sweat normal boxers don't separate it at
all obviously and now that you know that
there is another better option you'll
never go back sheep has this inverted
kangaroo pouch for your Joey to keep
from sticking to your thigh you'll chafe
and readjust way less because everything
is in a separate compartment and because
everything is separate there's less
smell too they were invented by a US
Army veteran who came up with the idea
for sheath during his second tour in
Iraq where it is hot as hell and his
undercarriage was underserved by
traditional underwear so we invented
sheath to keep everything cool and
comfortable and now that winter is
coming sheath has released some great
new winter gear to keep you and the boys
nice and cozy all winter long like their
dual pouch base layers and a fitted
bamboo hoodie and she ships super fast
so your order will arrive in just a few
days and take a look at all the reviews
on their website for official proof
click the link below and use the code
new rockstars at checkout or go to
sheathunderwear.com new rockstars for 20
off at sheathunderwear.com new rockstars
or just click the link below and use the
code new rockstars for 20 off trust me
your balls will thank you now here I'm
officer watch we gotta remind you all of
the recent hints to the guy in Thor 11
thunder in omnipotent City Zeus
referenced Satan in the background if
you listen closely
[Music]
human Souls sacrificed in the name of a
God these Gods aren't gonna help but
that Thunderball I think that might be
of use
and then of course in episode 4 of
Shield we saw Madison with two ends in a
y but now what do you think being sent
to a hell Dimension with skulls on
spikes and lava caverns and Madison
returning with a bloody human heart from
a demon goat named Jake in the closing
credits art we saw Jake with a name tag
which I'll try not to take as a personal
take these lighthearted knots Mephisto
do line up with the casting of a comedic
actor in this role though Sasha Baron
Cohen has range getting Awards by his
first betrayal of Abby Hoffman in the
trial of Chicago seven the truth is that
Mephisto can lurk anywhere regardless of
the tone of the title has the devil can
hide behind Any Corner in any Shadow
with a tempting deal for any hero we say
not today Satan because Satan can drop
by any day but I think there's a secret
double meaning in the title iron heart
when you look at Mephisto as a dealer in
human hearts and claiming Souls Riri as
a technologist has a heart of iron she's
uniquely immune to the seductions of a
devil promising Supernatural power
because for an engineer like her power
comes from a soldering iron it's a lot
like when Loki tried to use his scepter
to turn Tony Stark heart evil
this usually works well performance
issues Tony's ironheart saved him in
that moment the deadline report
suggested Sasha Baron Coates Mephisto
could be introduced in ironheart so that
he would then appear in other MCU titles
beyond that Agatha the coven of chaos
seems like a likely option Agatha was a
Salem witch in 1693 and historic leafy
and other witches during that era did
consider themselves lovers and wives of
Satan and in the comics One Division was
based on Agatha was a servant of
Mephisto and coming out of this series
there is so much more to the origin of
the dark hold how it got in the hands of
that coven and from the prologue of
werewolf by night we got a lot of
questions about the backstory of
Supernatural lore in the MCU and now
that blade is being delayed a year with
a page one rewrite Mephisto might be
part of those plans as well it could be
telling that the same week we learned
Marvel Studios is Delane blade it is the
same week it gets out that they're
hiring Sasha Baron Cohen as Mephisto
this could line up with blade meeting
Dane Whitman in the Eternal post-credits
scene and set up a midnight Sons team up
consisting of Blade and black knight and
Moon Knight and Elsa Bloodstone and Jack
Russell and Ghost Rider God I hope that
heart that Madison had but belong to
Johnny Blaze comment down below and
follow me on Tick Tock Instagram and
Twitter at eavos follow new rockstars
subscribe to new Rockstar some more
analysis of everything you love thanks
for watching bye
[Music]